Such a fucking benefit for me.
It's like when the world gets weird and
the world, my world is weird as fuck man.
You know, I try to explain it to people.
I'm like weird being me, you know?
And to be able to just
take some time and just go,
it's just look at it
all through fresh eyes.
Like that's the place for me of that tank.
Do an hour.
I like an hour.
But I do too.
If I have the time I like two
hour session would be yeah, God.
And then you have it here
is what it's all about.
So I can just do it anytime I want.
Hell yeah.
Like I wake up at three o'clock in the
morning. You just drive over here. Sweet.
You w what's your morning routine like?
Or do you have a morning routine
that you like? Are you sure?
Kind of fasted cardio. That's
what I like to do. Or fasted yoga,
that's my most recent thing as I'm doing
either 14 to 16 hours depending upon
what my day looks like.
Intermittent fasting. And then, uh,
I usually either like yoga or running in
the morning today was running and then
I'll do something in the afternoon.
Either martial arts related
or weightlifting related.
Do you, uh, do you drink coffee
every morning? Like when you were,
when you wake up or,
not always, but I like it. I like these
things. She's Nitros who's caveman?
Nitros a lot like regular coffee too,
but I drink water with Himalayan salt in
it too. That's one of the first things.
Yeah. I can put a little
lemon in there two times.
Sometimes I'll throw a little
cayenne pepper in that mother fucker.
Any apple cider vinegar to that stuff
sometimes too. I take a lot of probiotics,
a lot of, I eat a lot of Kimchi. I
find like Kimchi and game meat is like,
I've been on this kick for the past three
or four months where I just eat Kimchi
and l collect three, four times
a week. I mean, on stuff do it.
It's hard when you eat some elk before
bed and you wake up hard as a rock on the
fuck people up. People
don't know, man know. Wow,
you're heating a super athlete.
If you eat elk, your eat,
you're literally eating a super
athlete, you know, that's bad ass.
It's like a huge, like another
reason, not just a doctor Andy,
but listening to you,
you talk about it because it's
in your podcast all the time.
Talk about how how beneficial eaten those
kind of meats are. And I'm just like,
God, I got to do it. And I would just,
I feel, I feel so much better doing it.
Well if you think about like how health
see it is eat salmon,
like a healthy wild salmon that is a,
an animal that's out there hustling,
you know,
a salmon making its way up river.
You eat one of those things is just
loaded with nutrients and essential fats.
And when you eat an elk man,
you're eating an animal that's getting
away from wolves and bears and fighting
to the death with swords
grown out of its head.
I mean literally it's a forest horse
with fucking spears grown out of its head
and they're just out there
hustling Sirius all day. You know,
living out in Montana in the winter,
in the middle of the fucking winter,
running from wolves and shit.
I mean, that's their life.
You eat one of those things you eat.
It's like, Oh fuck you get charged up.
It feels, I've given it to people that
never eaten it before and they're like,
Holy Shit. And I'm like, yeah, you
feel different, right. You feel
even there.
Their DNA.
Do you ever do listen to Paul Chek, Paul
Chek, he's the Juco condo guy, right,
isn't he? No. He's been on
Aubrey's and stuff. He's a no,
I'm thinking of Paul Vernac. I'm
thinking of different guy. Yeah,
I've have listened to Paul
Chek. I listened to him on
Aubrey's pot is amazing.
Fuck,
he's a wizard.
He was explaining how a pasture raised
eggs versus just regular eggs that were
literally eating the DNA of
that chicken and it was he,
I don't remember what exactly he
said, but it blew my mind. I was like,
he's awesome. He would. That'd be,
that'd be a good podcast. You and him,
that would be sweet.
[inaudible] showed me so sweet chickens,
they love to eat.
Bugs and worms and grass and they love
to roam around and if they are allowed to
do that,
they get a dark,
like an orange yolk that you just don't
get from those God damn grocery store,
egg, chicken souls, grocery store,
chickens are prisoners getting little
prisoner eggs eaten that putting it into
your body,
it's better than nothing,
but it's nothing like a farm
raised free ranging chicken egg.
And you could get those at farmer's
markets and stuff like that, like,
but you could tell the moment you crack
them open. Yeah. I mean it's just orange,
like the sun, you know, take care
of your chickens. Yeah. Y'All have
whatsapp. Are they a pain? It's not the
easiest thing really. You know? Yeah.
You got to clean the shit and you got
to make sure they have enough food.
And for me,
I've got a squirrel problem.
My wife wants to kill the
fucking squirrels. Me. I'm like,
they're cute little fellas. Right?
But they steal all the food.
They're fat fucking squirrels.
They keep figuring out a way to get
into the chicken coop and get all the
chicken food.
And they're just in there all the time.
But now I might have to put them to
death because I found out they'd been
stealing eggs. The squirrels have now
figured out that they can get eggs.
And so a squirrel was trying to roll an
egg out of the chicken coop through the
hole that he comes in. We caught doing
that. I didn't catch it. Catch them.
How are you going to get a little fucker?
I Dunno. I Dunno. I bet it feels good.
I've never,
I never hunted and uh,
but it feels good shooting and then
eating the meat you get good does.
I'm nervous though, because I feel like
I'd feel so guilty shooting an animal.
You will. I remember I shot up
there a little longer. Look at it.
We've got an egg that's yours.
I'll pull that back. Jamie.
This, I had no idea that squirrel's did
this. I had to find out on my own yard.
These little funny faces. Their egg
Steelers, Bro. They, how do they know?
How do they know? They're so cute.
They're so cute. How did they know?
They fucking know at Chad, a little
motherfucker. You got the chickens.
Chickens don't know what
to do. It's money. Yeah.
Squirrels or they're not smart,
but they're determined.
I think I might have to run a fucking
Arrow through a few of them. Yeah,
but I don't want to kill the squirrels.
That's the city.
You don't want them eating my eggs,
but I also don't want to kill them,
so I don't know what to do.
I know.